Decibels exist because radio numbers are
ridiculous.
The signal your antenna picks up from a repeater ten miles away can be a hundred
billion times weaker than the signal leaving that repeater's transmitter.
Nobody wants to do math with eleven zeros.
The decibel is how radio engineers make
those numbers small, friendly — and addable.
A decibel is a logarithmic way of writing
a ratio between two power levels.
Not an amount — a ratio.
Ten decibels means ten times the power.
Twenty decibels means a hundred times.
Thirty means a thousand.
Every ten decibels you add multiplies the
power by another ten.
The everyday anchor is a piano.
Each octave is the same-sized step to your
ear, but each one doubles the frequency.
Decibels do that for power: equal steps
that stand for equal multiplications.
Your ear and your radio both live on that kind of scale,
which is why decibels feel natural once they click.
Three numbers are worth memorizing.
Plus three decibels: double the power.
Minus three: half.
Plus ten: ten times.
That's it — every other value is a
combination.
Sixteen decibels?
That's ten plus three plus three: ten times
two times two — forty times the power.
You just did logarithms in your head
without noticing.
And here's the superpower: on a log scale,
multiplication becomes addition.
Follow a signal from transmitter to receiver — every cable loses a few decibels,
every antenna adds a few, the path between them takes away a hundred or more.
Instead of multiplying eleven-digit numbers, you
just add and subtract small ones down the chain.
That running sum is called a link budget, and
it's how every radio link on Earth is designed.
One trap.
A plain decibel is always relative — a
ratio between two things.
The moment you see a letter after it, it's become an absolute number, measured against a fixed reference:
d-B-m means compared to one milliwatt; d-B-F-S means compared to the loudest sample your SDR can represent.
Same math, different anchor.
You'll see all three flavors in GopherTrunk's dashboard: signal level in d-B-F-S,
signal-to-noise ratio in plain decibels, and hardware specs quoted in d-B-m.
Now they're not three mysteries — they're
one idea with three anchors.
So: decibels turn absurd ratios into small numbers, multiplication
into addition, and three memorized steps into fluent mental math.
The full write-up, with the formulas, is
linked below.